ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément moins de pannes
mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent leur vie ressemble assez peu à
ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus de terre ils
ont des choses à dire la france oubliée
c'est une rencontre avec ces citoyens
qui ne se résignent pas à la fatalité la
france oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne
voit jamais
[Musique]
m
je
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans les hauts
de france à valenciennes
[Musique]
je
bonjour bonjour bonjour à la liaison
jour bienvenue à l'ancienne merci à
l'opéra barre merci nous recevoir avec
grand plaisir merci de venir nous voir
dans cette institution de valenciennes
que dire de plus de 6 ans tout à fait on
a eu beaucoup de chance pour l'instant
alors on voit en 2020 ça s'est arrêté
c'est toute votre vie c'est toute ma vie
oui tout à fait la restauration est
toute ma vie j'ai toujours fait ça
depuis mes 15 ans et donc là vous est
fermé depuis on est fermé on le ferme et
de flemmards son art eu la chance de ré
ouvrir en juillet en mode barre et non
plus en mode discothèque et
malheureusement la dure fermer aussi
voilà donc là vous
c'est un lieu où il y avait quoi jusqu'à
600 personnes
sérieux on applaudit à peu près 1200
personnes par semaine du mercredi au
dimanche 10 au dimanche
vous employez combien de personnes on
avait au moins de mars 19 personnes et
donc la smala on est âgé plus qu'au 11
chômage partiel qu'on a du mal à avoir
donc c'est très important pour nous de
pouvoir avoir une perspective de la
réouverture aussi bien pour eux pour
nous que pour les clients aussi
et vous vous n'avez pas dead puisque
vous êtes dirigeant a on a en a pour
l'instant et en 1500 euros net par mois
par mois
on a on a un établissement qui nous
coûtent huit mille euros par mois avec
le charge en frais fixes on fera fixe
tout à fait et pour vous c'est possible
de
de réouvrir c'est possible nous l'avons
fait en juillet juillet août septembre
octobre
nous l'avons fait nous avons à rouvrir
arrête une distanciation de trois mètres
par table donc les deux pistes de temps
les deux épisodes ans que nous avons ont
été aménagés avec des tables les gens
vont respecter les gens venaient avec le
masque s'asseyait enlever le masque il
suivait le protocole et on n'a eu aucun
problème on a eu aucun cluster personne
n'a été malade personne n'a été
contaminé
gérard secours au coeur quand j'arrive
je sais que on allume les lumières comme
j'ai fait aujourd'hui on met un peu de
musique parce qu'il faut entretenir le
matériel et on sait qu'une personne va
venir
c'est dommage de laisser un
établissement comme le nôtre et les
discothèques en général en france de les
laisser mourir comme ça
est-ce que vous la comprenez ces deux
fermetures la fermeture je la comprends
il ya un problème il y a un virus il
faut pouvoir le il faut pouvoir se
vacciner faut pouvoir trouver les
vaccins et puis trouver l'antidote
seulement il ya une manière de faire qui
pour au moins dans notre métier là nous
on trouve que c'est pas bien géré on a
dépensé de l'argent pour des plexi pour
des produits anti et bactéricide
antivirus ide qui finalement deux mois
après sont toujours là une serre
toujours un
j'ai perdu 100 mille euros ici pour
l'instant de plus le man march moins
100000 euros
on est assez de professionnels en france
pour gérer un flux de clientèle pour
essayer de bien la gérer
il faut nous donner les moyens de le
faire catherine chouchou jean catherine
mouchet
alors vous vous travaillez avec alain si
vous faites la compta c'est ça alors je
les aide au niveau de la comptage des
cours de rock le jeudi ce qu'on appelle
le jeu dirt dit chez nous et puis j'ai
d'aussi derrière le bar
un week-end sur deux c'est ma deuxième
maison ici est donc là alors suis très
triste je suis triste pour nous dans un
premier temps pour tous les bars les
restaurateurs mais aussi les clients
psychologiquement c'est super compliqué
jamais j'aurais cru qu'on sera encore
fermée
cette heure ci on a des clients qui nous
envoie régulièrement des messages de
soutien en espérant voilà on va réouvrir
bientôt qui se sentent seuls qu'ils ont
besoin de danser parce que vaille à des
gens qui sont tout seuls et leur
échappatoire c'était nous en fait et
voilà c'est compliqué et triste pour
tout le monde
qu'est ce qui vous choque depuis 2006 qu
logiquement le mot non essentiels c'est
terrible c'est terry parce qu'il ya des
gens qui ont investi toute leur vie et
quand on leur dit vous êtes non
essentiels ils ont souvent investi toute
leur vie leur argent non on n'est pas
non essentiels les gens ont besoin de se
rencontrer et de s'amuser de boire un
verre de danser
et voilà ici pour ça je vous dis que
c'est c'est c'est tristan et je me dis à
être investi autant est on arrivé là
c'est ouais c'est triste parce que après
encore une fois c'est tout le monde on
est obligé de subir mais voilà au niveau
des aides c'est super compliqué on a dû
se séparer de de certaines personnes
donc on a quand même licenciés enfin
licenciés arrêter des cdd six personnes
ben là aussi en fait nous on est une
famille donc après se séparer de voilà
de nos collaborateurs ça aussi c'est
hyper frustrant alors oui il ya du
chômage partiel mais jusque quand et
toute façon nous on a besoin et envie de
revenir travailler
vous y croyez toujours à l'ouvert fait
la réouverture on garde espoir
on pense effectivement bas tous les gens
qui travaillent avec derrière parce que
il ya des fournisseurs au niveau des
restaurants il ya les artisans locaux et
en fait c'est ça qui est un petit peu
effarant c'est qu'ils se rendent pas
compte que c'est pas seulement voilà le
patron de discothèque c'est derrière il
ya plein de gens qui travaillent et il
ya plein de gens qui sont en détresse
mais enfin de détresse financière et
détresse sociale
il ya eu des manifestations à
valenciennes on s'est juste fait
entendre en disant da nous aussi on veut
on veut ré ouvrir et on est essentiel
parce qu'on est essentielle mais je suis
sûr de moi quand je dis ça merci
catherine des gitans prix on va les
promener le chien on va faire un petit
tour
le baladi le petit il a besoin
d'exercice aussi et voilà c'est bien y'a
papa c'est bien on va se promener
oui on va se promener
[Applaudissements]
ouais commerçants l'essentiel mais tu
l'as mis vraiment en vente ou non non
non non à valenciennes tout le monde a
fait son tout le monde a fait ça je
voulais bros
les grosses structures où les moyens des
structures ont mis le même panneau way
pour bien marquer le coup aubin marquer
le coup et dire voilà merci l'elysée bon
il ya 430 discothèque qui ont déjà mis
la clé sous la porte
c'est à peu près un tiers ouais tout à
fait on sait qu'on va être à 6 ans dans
les prochains jours et pas dans mon
optique de feurs d'un j'ai pas eu
d'autres formations dans ma vie j'ai pas
d'autres envies que de faire plaisir à
des gens de faire découvrir la musique
des cocktails des boissons de donner un
peu d'eux de bien-être à certaines
personnes on va rentrer la maison à
l'est voient la maison bien aller oui
c'est bien aller oui
ouais donc là pour pas perdre la main tu
tu t'entraînes à faire des cocktails
on s'affaire la fin des cocktails on
s'entraîne surtout à faire des des
nouveaux cocktails pour la nouvelle
future carte on espère on va travailler
proprement sur un tapis super vous avez
soif aux attaques est la vallée et on va
choquer
on va le faire goûter ça tu arrives à te
projeter et quand tu te projettes tu te
projettes aqua six mois un an plus loin
on nous a dit que ça serait peut-être
septembre pour les boîtes de nuit si un
certain pourcentage de la population a
été vaccinée
la perspective c'est de tenir
financièrement jusqu'en septembre
voilà c'est à dire on doit y arriver on
y arrive pour les gens qui nous font
confiance pour les clients qui nous
suivent sur les réseaux sociaux pour le
personnel encore une fois pour notre
famille pour notre famille c'est
important d'être positif et de tenir le
coup de se dire on va réouvrir on est
obligé les réouvrir
c'est illogique de dire un être humain
on n'a plus jamais vu mourir dans votre
coin et on veut plus entendre parler de
vous donc tu sais on finit toujours la
séquence par une photo oui et comme je
te voyais en train de faire des
cocktails je me suis dit que c'était le
bon moment
[Musique]
allez c'est bon one two three qui peut y
aller
magnifique tu peux le qui peut ajouter
hérésie
[Musique]